Okay, here's what I'm going to need you
to do. I'm going to need you to pull up
Goodreads or the story graph or a
notepad and pen if you're feeling
analog, I guess. Good for you. Fight the
system. I am going to need you to take
the day off of school or work. Phone and
sick. I will vouch for you. I will write
you a note. I need you to go to your
nearest bookstore. I need you to go to
your nearest library or audio book
provider. And I need you to read at
least one of these books, please. I'm
serious. You need these in your life. I
promise you, I'm going to pitch them to
you in this video. So, hopefully you can
find the one that interests you the
most. But of the 120 odd books that I
read last year, these are the best of
the best. Trust me on this one. This is
now your required reading. This is now
your syllabus. And I need you to know
that I am so dedicated to the cause of
telling you about these that I stopped
reading the new Hunger Games book to
tell you about them. Yeah, it's that
serious. It's that deep. So, in this
video, I will be talking about each of
these books. This is my public service
to you. If you would like to hear about
every single book that I read last year
reviewed in one sentence each, I made a
video about it. If you want to know
about the worst books that I read last
year, I also made a video about it.
You're a hater. I like you. I gave uh
Kendrick Lamar run for his money with
that video. So, just be prepared for
that one. But for now, we're here. I
adore these books. These are so
brilliant. And let's dive in. James,
this to me just immediately entered the
literary cannon. I know that sounds
crazy. I know that sounds ridiculous.
Trust me on this one. Like, I fully
appreciate that sounds like giving a
singer a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame for their debut single. It feels
like giving someone an Oscar for their
audition tape. But even though this book
just came out, I do believe that it
deserves its place in the literary
cannon. And here's why. There's kind of
a brand of books which are essentially
kind of like literary fanfiction. So you
have books like Whit Saraso that is a
retelling of Jane Air but from the
perspective of Bertha. Recently Sandra
Newman released a book called Julia
which is a retelling of 1984. Hell even
Milton's Paradise Lost is essentially
Bible fanfiction. So this book kind of
comes under that category. So 141 years
ago Mark Twain wrote a book called
Huckleberry Finn. If you don't know
Huckleberry Finn, I'm going to hold your
hand when I say this. I don't know how
you found my channel. Huckleberry Finn
is one of the most iconic kind of works
of American fiction. Actually, Mark
Twain claimed that he was the first
person to ever write a full book using a
typewriter. That's kind of a useless
fact. My literature degree is kind of a
long-term investment into being good at
pub quizzes, but I'm glad I could flex
that knowledge now. I actually wonder
what fragment of a childhood memory I
have forgotten in order to retain that
fact about Mark Twain. Anyway, all these
years on, the incredible writer Pul
Everett has written this book, which is
a retelling of Huckleberry Finn, but
from the perspective of Jim the Slave.
James, what was that? Why' I say that?
Like Wendy Williams. James is a book
about who gets a voice and who doesn't,
who is silenced, who has been
historically erased from the narrative.
In this book, the character of James is
articulate and he's astute, whereas Mark
Twain presents him as kind of gormless
and submissive. At one point, he even
asks the question, "Which would frighten
you more? A slave who is crazy or a
slave who is sane and sees you clearly?"
In Huckleberry Finn, Jim is kind of used
as a bit of a prop for the white
characters's journey of self-discovery.
In that book, everything is refracted
through the lens of Huckleberry Finn and
Tom Sawyer. Jim, on the other hand, is
silenced. But here, he at long last
becomes the focal point of his own
adventure. He is not just given a voice,
but a stage. This is a quote from the
book. I can tell you that I am a man who
is cognizant of his world. A man who has
a family, who loves a family, who has
been torn from his family, a man who can
read and write, a man who will not let
his story be self-related, but
self-written. This book is horrible at
times, but it's also hilarious. It's
dark, but it's also enlightening. And in
that sense, I think that Pival Everett
is faithful to the original tone of the
book of Huckleberry Finn. So, he pays
homage to the original whilst also
inventing something new. He says the
difficult things out loud and it isn't
patronizing. So, to me, this feels like
a modern classic that people will be
studying for a very long time and you
should get ahead of the curve. This is a
book that demands to be read, so you
should read it. Next up, we have All
Fours by Miranda July. Now, let me just
tell you, when I went to writing school
in New York City, there were two rules.
Number one was everybody has to write
and everybody has to share their work.
And number two was no one is a better
writer than Miranda July. I became
obsessed with her work through reading
it in my writing school program. And
when I saw that she'd released her first
book in a decade, I was very excited
about that. I bought it without even
reading a plot summary and I think that
it felt like a complete fever dream and
I'm so glad I got to experience it in
that way. It just keeps surprising you.
You never know what's going to come
next. Every time you turn the page
there's something batshit insane. Like
it is whacka doodle time with this book.
It is whack a doodle time. But also it's
not outside of the scope of what humans
are capable of. It's not like a fantasy
wonderland. This is deeply deeply human.
We follow a sort of larger than-l life
anti-hero. I say anti-hero because she's
definitely not really the hero of the
book, but she's a complicated villain as
well. She's sort of both simultaneously.
And that is part of the beauty of this
thought experiment. I guess this book is
about confronting your life as you reach
middle age. It's about realizing that
you are harvesting resentments of the
life that has in some ways been taken
away from you when you no longer have
potential or you no longer perceive
yourself to have that potential. She's
kind of proving to herself that she
does. She says this, "All of the
hormones that made me want to seem
approachable so I could breed are gone
and replaced by hormones that are
fiercely protective of my autonomy and
freedom." This woman leaves her husband
and her child behind as she ostensibly
takes a road trip from her home in LA to
a work event in New York City. But the
second that she starts to drive and she
gets in that car, she can't bring
herself to drive to New York and she
takes a turn on the road. She
deliberately drives herself to a nearby
motel and camps out there instead just a
few miles from home. And I think that
the hotel room as a setting is really
fascinating cuz it's this kind of liinal
space, right? It's a holiday from your
normal life, but that is constantly
problematized by the inevitability that
you will have to return. It is not
permanent. It is a temporary space. And
that's kind of the tension of this book.
There's a relaxed attitude towards
morality and decision-m, let's just say,
but also an awareness of real life to
return back to at some point where there
are responsibilities and there are
repercussions. She decides to hire an
interior designer to decorate the hotel
room that she is staying in. They
renovate it in quite ostentatious and
frivolous ways. And then the designer's
partner comes over to help with some of
the renovations. And our main character
just begins lusting over him. She
becomes pretty obsessed with him. I
would say you know that one friend who
every time you FaceTime them, they have
been up to something absolutely insane.
That's this character. Every chapter is
a new predicament or mental anguish or
preoccupation and it is honestly just
rip roaring fun. Like make literature
fun again. This is such a riot. And one
of her favorite pastimes is just lying
for no reason. She says for me lying
created just the right amount of
problems. And what you saw was just one
of my four or five faces, each real,
each with different needs. The only
dangerous lie was one that asked me to
compress myself down into a single
convenient entity that one person could
understand. I was a kaleidoscope. Each
glittering piece of glass changing as I
turned. I have been googling black
markets to find out if there is a place
I can sell my soul to read this again
for the first time. Truly, it's my
motivation to set up a book club this
year just so I can discuss this with
people. You know, has anyone been
watching the show Severance? I wish I
could get severed just so that my innie
could experience this for the first time
without having read it before. That's
how much this means to me. It's serious.
Now, before I move on to talking about
the next book, I wanted to firstly share
my honorary mentions. So, I'm going to
put them on screen right now. These are
the books that I loved this year so
much, but they didn't make my top 10.
These are all brilliant books, five
stars. I love them all dearly, but if I
would talk about them as well, we would
be here literally all day. And the other
thing I wanted to tell you about is that
today's video is very kindly sponsored
by Millerote. This is the best way of
putting down all of your thoughts into
one place and brainstorming, planning
out projects. You can make a board and
then put all of your information that
you need in one place. And it's so
intuitive and userfriendly because you
basically just drag and drop everything
that you need into the board that you
are creating. So to give you an example,
I created this one right here, which
shows you all of my top books for 2024
and kind of how they're linked. So the
red lines are thematic links and the
black lines other types of associations.
So like they were nominated for the same
award or they won the same prize because
I wanted to give you some kind of visual
representation of where you should
begin, where you could start, like which
book might peique your interest, and if
you like this kind of book, what else
you might like as well. It's kind of a
road map to the books that I loved this
year just to give you a better starting
point, I guess, a more helpful entrance
point. So, using Millanote, you can
create project plans. You can create
mood boards. It's an online canvas
designed to help you plan, brainstorm,
and collaborate on ideas. You can use a
variety of elements such as notes,
images, website links, sketches, task
cards, color swatches. Millerote is
designed to help you plan and organize
your creative projects. For me, I have
to see things visually in order for me
to be able to process them. So for me, I
need this kind of a platform which is
flexible and unstructured to just throw
all of my ideas at and then I can neaten
it up and make it all make sense in the
way that I would most helpfully process
it. Millerote makes starting a new
project easy with over 100 built-in
templates available for every type of
creative project. You can even write a
book using Millerote. They have these
amazing templates to plan out plot
lines, to help you with creating
characters. When you're ready to share
your work, you can invite your team to
gather important feedback and
collaborate with them in real time. And
the best part is Milano is available for
free. So you can sign up using the link
in my description and get planning your
creative projects right now. Thank you,
Milano. We love you, Milano. And on with
the next book. Boulder by Eva Baltazar
ponders similar questions. This asks the
question, what is more important, love
or freedom? So, we follow a woman who
works for a boat and when the boat docks
in Barcelona, she gets off and has this
crazy one night stand and she kind of
falls in love with the lady that she had
the one night stand with. And so, the
boat goes away again for a while. 3
months of lusting over this lady pass
and then when she comes back to
Barcelona, she's ready to like confess
her love to her and the lady tells her
she's moving to Iceland. So, our
protagonist does the only rational thing
that you do in this situation and moves
to Iceland with her. I will say usually
I write notes at poetry about my
situationships, but to each their own.
Move to Iceland. Sure, Rekuik sounds
nice. The trouble is once they arrive in
Iceland, the lady says to her, "I want
to have a baby and I want to have it
right now." And as someone who has
always imagined her life without
children, this is not just a curveball
for our main character, but like a
football to the face. A football to the
face with glasses on. You know how that
hurts? They go through with IVF
treatment and it's successful first time
and suddenly there's a baby and we face
a moral dilemma. If our character wants
to be free, then she has to lose the
person that she loves. If she wants to
be loved, then she has to sacrifice her
freedom. And realizing that something
has to be compromised here sends her
spiraling. All this tunneling has opened
rifts through which the captive parts of
me have started to emerge. I realize
that I am smoke, that the things that
define me rise as they would up a
chimney, probing every crack, searching
for a wellspring of light or cold, a
cupul of sky to sprawl into. I love that
imagery. these fundamental parts of you
that are desperate to emerge and they'll
start to manifest in any way they
possibly can. Eva Baltazar's writing
just drips liquid poetry off the page.
It is sharp. It's also lyrical and packs
such an emotional punch. In fact, I'm
glad that it's short because then it
won't hurt as much when I get every line
from this book tattooed onto my body.
Seriously though, this book I kind of
experienced a sort of book hangover
after finishing it because I was like, I
don't know how I'm going to find
something as good as that. Thankfully,
there are two other books in this sort
of series. It's a trilogy written by Eva
Basar, translated by Julia Sanchez from
the Catalan. This is actually the middle
book, but you don't need to have read
any of the others to understand it. So,
the one before is called Perafrost, and
the one after is called Mammoth. I've
read all three, and I will say I think
this is the best one. And the books
aren't linked in terms of plot. That's
why I say you don't need to have read
the other ones in order to understand.
There's kind of more of a thematic link
between them. There's no crossover, but
I think the point of this project was to
study the grievances and the conundrums
and the frustrations of women. So, we
follow three similar women in different
scenarios. This is a must readad and
it's also, I will say, dare I say, proof
that sex scenes and smart can be
literary. This is smoking hot. And if
you needed further evidence of that
fact, this is another book which does
the same thing. This makes sex scenes
feel so literary. This is The Safekeep,
which follows a very house proud woman.
One day, her brother turns up to her
house and he's like, "Hey, my
girlfriend's going to live with you for
a bit. Hope that's okay, Rita. It was It
was not okay. It was so far from okay.
She is fuming. She hates this woman. She
makes Drake and Kendrick Lamar look like
puppies playf fighting. That's how
violent and aggressive her hatred is.
You see the way her brother's girlfriend
just infuriates her. Like there are
seven trillion nerves in the human body
and this woman manages to get on every
single one. But eventually this book
becomes more than just rivalry and
etiquette. It's a story really of
ownership and of heritage and desire and
ultimately war. It's an often untold
story of the Second World War where, you
know, the war doesn't end just when the
final bullet is fired. The repercussions
echo and reverberate for decades, for
centuries even. And that's where we're
at, where these two characters lives
collide. I absolutely flew through this
book. Quite literally, I was flying. I
opened the first page of this book as I
boarded a flight as I sat down in my
seat and then I closed the final page as
we landed. I could not you could not pry
me away from this even with a very good
selection of films. I will say I I
didn't even look at them because I was
just absolutely hooked on this. You
would have to pry this book out of my
white knuckled hands like Jack we've
landed. You have to get off. I was like
no I'm I'm reading this until the end.
phenomenal, but also insane that this is
a debut piece of fiction. It's just that
good. I love this quote. You kind of get
an idea of the infatuation. The canals
had frozen over. Isabelle tested one
with her foot and found it solid and
then stood on it in wonder. A miracle,
she thought, to stand so solidly on what
could also engulf you. Because really,
it's not about frozen canals. It's about
people. And I think that is reflected in
the fact that this book is not just
about people. It's actually an allegory
for so much more. There's also this
great quote about longing for someone
after they've gone. She had held a pair
in her hand and she had eaten it skin
and all. She had eaten the stem and she
had eaten its seeds and she had eaten
its core and the hunger still sat in her
like an open moore. She thought, "I can
hold you and find that I still miss your
body." She thought, "I can listen to you
speak and still miss the sound of your
voice." It was nominated for the Booker
Prize this year, as was my next pick,
which actually won the prize. This
precious little book is the perfect
antidote to the world that we are seeing
around us right now. It feels like a
really tough time to exist within
culture and society and to try and
navigate that. But this book I feel is
the bomb that we all need. It's so
soothing and generous and pure. Orbital
is a book about six astronauts and
cosmonauts in space who with the vantage
point of distance staring at the Earth
all day become weirdly protective over
our little planet. They're all from
different countries. And I think it's a
necessary reminder that national borders
are something we created. Passports are
something of human invention. Visas are
a human creation. These things are
implemented to say we are different.
Different countries have different visa
rules for different people because they
essentially divide us up into
categories. In this book, you have two
Russians, an American, someone from
Italy, someone from the UK, someone from
Japan. So you have there such an
interesting little microcosm with
countries and people who may have
considered each other enemies, people
who may have considered each other foes.
And yet this setting, this space,
literally space, is a great equalizer.
In orbital, Samantha Harvey says, "Think
a new thought, they sometimes tell
themselves. The thoughts you have in
orbit are so grandiose and old. Think a
new one, a completely fresh, unthought
one. But there are no new thoughts.
They're just old thoughts born into new
moments. And in these moments is the
thought. Without that earth, we are all
finished. We can't survive a second
without its grace. We are sailors on a
ship on a deep, dark, unswimable sea.
It's contemplative and deeply deeply
moving. And in turn, it makes you feel
kind of proud of the planet and of being
an inhabitant of planet Earth. And in
equal measure, I think this book made me
kind of angry. Angry at the people who
have made this earth a divided place and
who seek to divide us further. People in
power right now who seek to point out
our differences rather than our
similarities. You know, the similarities
at the core of our beings. So to me,
although this was small and subtle, it
was also galvanizing. It's a rallying
call that we don't need to be so
divided. Like that isn't the logical
way. We have a natural tendency as
humans towards compassion and kindness
and yet we focus on who is allowed to
travel across which imaginary boundary.
And so when you think about the booker
prize the question is not just which are
the books that are the best written
although that is a component that's an
ingredient to the formula. I think it's
also you have to ask yourself the
question what is the book that will
define this year? What is the book that
speaks to some sort of universal truth
that we need to acknowledge? I think
that's what this book does. It speaks to
our contemporary predicament. It speaks
to and for the present moment. Orbital
was without a doubt the winner of last
year's book of prize. I love this book.
It's kind of cleansing in a way. It
feels kind of cathartic to read. So, I
will say if you are feeling a little
worldw weary and you want to just slow
down and linger, pick this one up. It is
deceptively short, but it is worth
taking your time over and really
embracing each page and the ideas that
it presents. There are lots of big ideas
for such a small volume. And Samantha
Harvey is really committed to dissecting
things, pulling them apart, ruminating
on them, considering them deeply, I
loved this. And when I name my firstborn
child orbital, mind your own business.
Okay, next. Martr. Oh my god, please can
we talk about Martyr? There is a reason.
There is an exclamation mark in the
title of this book because you will want
to talk about it at full volume. You
will want to shout martyr at everyone
you see telling them they have to pick
up this book. They have to read this
book. And that's what I'm going to do
for you right now. Oh my god. Oh, she
passed away. I just threw that into my
lap where there are some tender areas
you do not want to throw a hardback book
into like that. Oh my god. Okay, moving
on. This is not just one of my best
books of the year. This is one of the
best books I have ever read. Ironically,
I would die on that hill. I will be the
martyr for this cause. This book covers
a lot of philosophical ground, but
plot-wise, we follow a an Iranian
American man who is a poet and his mom
was killed in a US sort of military air
disaster. So, her plane was shot down by
the US military and she died. So he's
always had a fragile relationship with
death and the concept of a martyr. And
then he sees that a terminally ill
artist is hosting an exhibition in a
museum in Brooklyn where basically she
will talk to anyone who comes and sits
across from her. It's kind of like you
know that exhibition or project that
Marina Abramovich did. I think it was
called the artist is present where she
would like sit and people could come and
sit across from her and they would sit
in silence. This is that but for
yappers. This artist in this book, the
fictional one, will talk to the person
who comes and sits across from her. And
so our narrator has this total
preoccupation with death and so the
opportunity to go and speak to someone
who knows they are about to die is
exciting for him. And so he flies to
Brooklyn and he sits and he has a series
of conversations with this artist and
those conversations are revoly. So I
loved that. But one of the other things
I really liked about this book was how
thoughtfully it considered goodness and
grace. He says it's hard not to envy the
monsters when you see how good they have
it and how unbothered they are at being
monsters. You know goodness every day
becomes a choice. Living with this
belief that humans are fundamentally
good is a choice that you have to make
every single day because it will be
constantly challenged. That ideology
will be corrupted every time you go out
and see human beings acting appallingly.
But there is a belief that humans have a
natural propensity towards goodness. I
suppose this book invokes a lot of
historical figures and philosophers and
thinkers and so you actually learn a lot
while reading it as well. like a whistle
stop tour through philosophy, I guess.
And it provides you with beautiful new
ways to articulate the things that you
see around you and human behavior to an
extent. There was a section I wanted to
read to you. I mean, I underlined almost
the entire book because the writing is
that good, but um this page
specifically. When asked about the
difficulties of sculpture, Michelangelo
said, "It is easy. You just chip away
all the stone that isn't David. It's
simple to cut things out of a life. You
break up with a shitty partner, quit
eating bread, delete the Twitter app,
you cut it out. And the shape of what's
actually killing you clarifies a little.
The whole Abrahamic world invests itself
in this promise. Don't lie, don't cheat.
Don't [__] or steal or kill, and you'll
be a good person. Eight of the Ten
Commandments are about what thou shalt
not do. But you can live a whole life
not doing any of that stuff and still
avoid doing any good. That's the whole
crisis. The rot at the root of
everything. The belief that goodness is
built on a constructed absence. Not
doing that belief corrupts everything.
Has everyone with any power sitting on
their hands. A rich man goes a whole day
without killing a single homeless person
and so goes to sleep content in his
goodness. In another world, he's buying
crates of socks and cliff bars and
tents, distributing them in city
centers. But for him, abstinence reigns.
I want to be the chisel, not the David.
What can I make of being here and what
can I make of not? In that way, I feel
like it's wise, but the book is also
curious because we're going on the
journey with the narrator. He
contemplates and ruminates on his ideas
and he also changes his mind. And on top
of all of that, I think it's also a book
about heartbreak and despair and
alcoholism and suicide. And it's not
only one of my favorite books I read
last year, but a new favorite of all
time. And so for that matter is this
one. This is evenings and weekends and
this is just a love story to London.
It's set over the course of a
swelteringly hot weekend. And I think
that the weather in this book makes it
feel all the more claustrophobic. It
feels like all of the characters are
just on top of each other and too close
for comfort and closing in. Everyone is
in each other's business. We have a big
ensemble cast of characters, so it kind
of feels like a soap opera or a Richard
Curtis film. like you know a modern day
love actually. This is the real
housewives of northeast London and I
devoured it. The city of London almost
appears like a character in this book in
its own right. Oshin McKenna points out
that the city can just act as a backdrop
but in this book it becomes a playground
for exploration and each character is
fighting their own battle. You know we
have a couple who are engaged to be
married. We have a couple who are
expecting a baby but aren't sure if
they're ready to settle their lives down
and pin themselves to one place. There's
a mother who has been diagnosed with
cancer and needs to tell her son. A
character navigating an open
relationship, people discovering their
sexuality early on but also later in
life. And it kind of made me think of
the concept of s. S is the idea that or
the realization that everyone around you
is living as complex a life as you are.
Everyone has as much going on in their
brain as you do. And I like that the
title is pluralized evenings and
weekends because it sort of suggests
that this is just one weekend in a very
long and complicated life. Each of these
characters has had many weekends and
will have many afterwards. This is just
one of them. What makes this weekend
unique is that there is a whale stuck in
the river temps. So basically this whale
has got itself in a bit of a jam and all
of the media outlets are covering it,
but there's one lady in particular who
is reporting on the whale and she
happens to look a lot like Princess
Diana. And so everyone refers to her as
the princess of whales. Get it? So the
book is funny, but what I love most
about it is that there are no villains.
You know, there are characters who make
mistakes and betray themselves and
betray others. They have flaws. They're
fallible, but each one is written with
empathy and compassion. We understand to
an extent how they come to the decisions
that they do. And in that way, Oshene
McKenna writes each one with fairness, I
think, and they feel so real. It feels
like each one of these characters could
just jump off the page into the room
that you're sitting in and you could
have a conversation with them. They feel
so three-dimensional. We see that in our
lives. We see the way that people expand
and change over time. And this is what
Oshin McKenna says. There is too much to
say and no way to say it. It's
impossible for anyone to describe the
detail of their life, the
minute-to-minute transition from one
thought to the next. And unless you
speak to a person on a regular basis,
how can you know what their life is
like? You can't. The book discusses how
money and social class permeate
everything. It's about the city and sex
and intimacy and partying, but also
aging and coming to terms with the
development of your life and how at
first everything is fun and potential
and silly and chaotic, but eventually
you have to start making decisions that
have long-term effects. And to be quite
frank, I think this is the perfect book.
So that's evenings and weekends.
Sticking with the hot and sweaty summer
vibes, this is Last Summer in the City.
This one was originally published a
while back, but it's so existential and
the troubles that the character faces
are so real and raw that it kind of
feels eternal. First published in 1973,
Last Summer in the City is about a man
frittering around Rome in this alcoholic
haze. Sometimes experiencing the city to
be sweet and sublime, but at other
times, sometimes at the same time
finding Rome to be a cruel landscape.
Here's a quote. Rome by her very nature
has a particular intoxication that wipes
out memory. She's not so much a city as
a wild beast hidden in some secret part
of you. There can be no half measures
with her. Either she's the love of your
life or you have to leave her because
that's what the tender beast demands to
be loved. If she's loved, she'll give
herself to you whichever way you want
her. All you need to do is go with the
flow and you'll be within reach of the
happiness that you deserve. You will
have summer evenings glittering with
lights, vibrant spring mornings, cafe
tablecloths ruffled by the wind like
girls skirts, keen winters, and endless
autumns. Every now and again, someone
did get the hell out. Our central
character, Leo, is told by friends, you
cannot go on like this. But I suppose
his curse is that he knows that he
actually kind of can. And so he prevails
and he keeps wandering on this
destructive and disaffected path. On his
journey, he considers love and lust,
suicidal ideiations, the sea, the city,
books, but maybe because of the alcohol,
there is a certain numbness sort of
instilled in his perception of things.
He's kind of disillusioned and the tone
is truly unforgettable. If you are
wanting to read a character's
perspective where you just feel every
single line, every single letter in your
soul, this is the book to read. I feel
like it really stands up to be as iconic
as books like The Catcher in the Rye and
The Great Gatsby. Like, let me just read
from page one to give you a sense of the
tone because straight out the gate, it
is kind of iconic, I think. So, it
starts like this. Anyway, it's always
like that. You do your best to keep to
yourself and then one fine day, without
knowing how, you find you're caught up
in something that sweeps you along with
it to the bitter end. Personally, I
would have happily stayed out of the
race. I'd known all kinds of people,
some who'd reached the finishing post
and others who hadn't even gotten off
the starting block. And sooner or later,
they all ended up equally dissatisfied,
which is why I'd come to the conclusion
that it was better to stay on the
sidelines and just observe life. But I
hadn't reckoned with being desperately
short of money one rainy day at the
beginning of spring last year. All the
rest followed naturally, as these things
do. Let me make it clear from the start
that I don't blame anyone. I was dealt
my cards and I played them. That's all.
But also, what I would say is that the
cards he's being dealt are constantly
being reshuffled. The people he meets
are as meaningful as those he's left
behind. And we eventually build up a
sort of mosaic of this man through the
pros on his meandering route through the
city. This feels like an outof body
experience. I adore this book. Okay,
we're nearly there. This is the
penultimate book. This is Chyros written
by Jenny Urinbeck and translated by
Michael Hoffman. This actually won last
year's International Booker Prize, which
I had the honor of hosting. It's so
funny because as the host and as someone
who is interviewing all the different
authors, you have to kind of remain a
little impartial, but I was secretly
hoping for this one to win. It's set in
East Berlin before and after the fall of
the Berlin Wall. So, it's a very
fascinating historical setting, but also
this is a book on a personal level about
love and betrayal about two characters
who meet each other on the bus by
complete chance and their chemistry is
just completely electric and so intimate
almost immediately. You know, when you
just you just have a spark with someone,
you just have that immediate click and
it's like, "Oh, it's you." You know? Oh,
how could it have ever been anyone else?
That's how it feels. this love affair
just becomes allconsuming. It is so
special to read and it just sort of
bubbles up inside them. If you've ever
had an incredibly intense crush or a
situationship, you will eat this one up.
And the language that they use to
describe one another and the way that
they converse and the dialogue, it just
dances on the page. Truly, I need this
to be made into a movie. I need to see
two people bring this to life as well.
The book actually gets its title from
the god Kyros in reference to the
fleeting nature of this love affair.
Chyros, the god of fortunate moments, is
supposed to have a lock of hair on his
forehead, which is the only way of
grasping hold of him. Because once the
god has slipped past on his winged feet,
the back of his head is sleek and
hairless, nowhere to grab hold of. And
it's sort of about how like once a
relationship has ended, sweetness really
leaves no souvenir, you know? It's like
I swear I had these feelings and I swear
I was part of momentary bliss, but I
have nothing tangible to hold on to
anymore and to say look here it is. I've
experienced this joy. You know, if you
get hurt, if you get injured, you have a
scar to prove it. But this bliss doesn't
leave anything. And so that's where our
character is left sort of grasping at
that piece of hair that they can no
longer see. And really too, this book is
an allegory about a nation that has
ceased to exist. the ending I will never
recover from. So, Jenny Urban, you are
single-handedly responsible for my
therapy bills because what the hell,
Jenny, you tore my heart in two. Again,
it's definitely cathartic and it feels
like such a purge of the emotions
because you feel every single particle
of that tangible connection these two
characters seem to have. And then you
two are left sort of clutching to be
like, "Wait, I swear it was here
somewhere." You know, it's a really
moving experience. I love books written
with a free indirect discourse style.
What that means is that you can see both
characters perspectives simultaneously.
They don't know each other's
perspectives, but we as the reader have
the kind of vantage point of being able
to see inside both of their heads. Sort
of like normal people in a way. If you
like that book, I think you will really
love this one, too. It's about loyalty.
It's about cruelty. It's about how two
people navigate the ruins of a
relationship and also its intensity.
Come, darling May, and put the buds back
on the trees. The piano wishes at the
end, but it's July now. The summer
evening outside has turned into a summer
night. The bottle of wine is empty. Do
you feel hungry? Sure. Then let's go
eat. Sure. It feels good to be walking
beside him, she thinks. It feels good to
be walking beside her, he thinks. And
just to round us off, here is another
book about a fleeting love affair.
There's a bit of a trend this year. The
final book I wanted to recommend to you
in this video is Madonna in a fur coat.
This is a Turkish classic by Sabahhatin
Ali, but again reading it, it just feels
completely brand new. Like it feels
modern. The emotions are contemporary
just as they probably were so moving
when it was first written as well. So at
first when they first meet, he says,
"Suddenly I felt light-hearted, even
brave. As I watched the waiter standing
there tottsing up the figures, I had the
overwhelming urge to smile and say,
"Just look how happy I am, you fools." I
wanted to salute every customer in the
room, throw my arms around them all,
even the musicians, and embrace them
like longlost friends. It's about how
love, especially in its early days of
being like freshly flowering and
blossoming, is so allconsuming. It seems
to give you those kind of rose tinted
glasses where everything feels
incredible. But this bliss in this book
at least is momentary and it becomes so
harrowing. I want to say this man is
dramatic but aren't we all? But later
once this woman is gone his whole life
feels kind of hollow. It's almost like
because he's had it because he's felt it
now it's absence is so painful. You
know, she had swept me away from my dark
and silent world, delivering me to the
land of truth and light. And now she had
vanished, offering no reasons and as
suddenly as she'd come. But for me,
there was no hope of sinking back into
my old torpour. For as long as I lived,
I would travel far and wide, meeting
with people whose languages I did or did
not know. And everywhere I went, I would
be looking for a Maria Puda. In every
pair of eyes, I would be searching for
the Madonna in a fur coat. I knew from
the outset that I would never find her.
Yet, it was not in my power to give up
searching. She had condemned me to a
lifelong quest for a cipher, for someone
that did not exist. She should never
have done this to me. So, a lot of
emotional intensity going on in this
one, too. It's moving. It's memorable.
It's full of yearning and melancholy,
and it will make you want to weep, which
is basically all I'm looking for in a
book. If a book makes me cry, I
basically am like, well, I'm yours for
life. I will tell everyone about this. I
will shout about it from the rooftops.
Thank you so much for that experience.
So, that's how I feel about this book.
It's not just a book. It's not just a
story, but it's also an experience and
it took me for a ride, trust me. So,
those are the books that I wanted to
tell you about. Let me know which one
you are thinking of reading in the
comments section or what your best books
of 2024 were that you read. I thoroughly
recommend each and every one of these
books that I spoke about today. I hope
that you enjoy them. Let me know if you
read them, what you think. I think that
they each present a lot of food for
thought. I think they each present a
real intensity of emotions, as I've
said, but also gorgeous pros, lyrical
writing, just such a treat. So special.
I'm very jealous that you get to read
them for the first time. Thank you so
much for being here. Thank you for
watching this video. You can follow me
on Tik Tok and Instagram to see what I'm
reading now, what I'm getting up to. My
second channel, of course, where I share
my monthly reading. So, I share like
what I'm planning to read each month.
And then this channel is more for like
my reviews. And that's everything. I
hope that I can find books as good as
these ones this year. All the best. Have
a wonderful day and I'll catch you very,
very soon. Bye-bye.